j'accueille maintenant didier lestrade
il y restera bon soir vous êtes
journaliste à têtu cofondateur de
l'acteur faisait déjà publié deux livres
chez denoël dont act up une histoire et
vous publié aujourd'hui viande
toujours chez denoël vous partez d'un
constat simple depuis l'arrivée des
trithérapies en 1996 le sida me fait
plus peur
c'est ce qui explique le phénomène du
bareback alors le bareback pour nos amis
téléspectateurs qui ne seraient pas au
courant c'est l'abandon de la capote c
c'est un nouveau style de vie après 25
ans d'épidémie ou des gens sont fatigués
de la capote et et finissent par
revendiquer le fait de refuser la capote
et je crois que ce livre c'était la
première fois qu'on fait un livre sur la
prévention milieu gay parce que je suis
très inquiet de sa saveur
c'est quelque chose qui après 15 ans
d'activisme me fait beaucoup de mal et
de voir que l'épidémie reprend chez les
homosexuels c'est forcément un moment
bien sûr c'est un sujet grave mais c'est
un moment c'est quelque chose
c'est un sujet qui mérite quand même
qu'on s'insurge et non seulement à
l'intérieur de son propre groupe c'est à
dire que moi je me suis toujours battu
dans la lutte contre le sida et et je
suis un peu triste quand je vois que les
choses commencent à 1 à à tourner mal
oui quand on lit votre bouquin on a
l'impression c'est un peu eux rien ne va
plus chez les homos la communauté perd
ses repères quoi on s'est un peu excusez
moi il ya plus de morale quoi les jeunes
par exemple qui arrive à 20 ans ils
n'ont pas vraiment connu ce qu'on a
connu nous moi je suis sûr au pot depuis
17 ans et c'est vrai que même quelqu'un
de mon âge c'est très difficile de
parler un jeune et de leur expliquer en
quoi c'est vraiment important de rester
séronégatif et qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour se protéger et c'est vrai que
moi ça fait depuis cinq ans six ans que
je vois cette idée de bareback grandir
de plus en plus dans la communauté gay à
un moment on a cru que c'était un
fantasme
c'était un délire de ma part et je crois
que maintenant on a des chiffres qui
montrent que d'année en année ça
augmente dans tous les pays qui sont
autour de chez nous et je crois que 20 %
d'augmentation en angleterre l'année
dernière pour une seule année ça veut
dire que il suffit cinq ans comme
saillon double non
de calculer baker pour vous c'est un
petit peu des kamikazes quoi des
kamikazes nihiliste qui disent après moi
le déluge il ya une partie des gens qui
ont vraiment envie d'être d'être ni
liste oui ben il ya aussi des gens tout
simplement qu'ils baissent les bras en
baisse les bras parce que c'est vraiment
très dur de considérer que tous les
jours il faut mettre la capote et je
crois que la prévention était vraiment
dans une situation vraiment de crise en
france c'est à dire que les associations
je crois ont baissé la garde vraiment et
je crois que l'état en profite et que du
coup à partir du moment parle pas de
prévention et bien les gens sont
désemparés ils savent vraiment à ce
qu'il faut faire
le sentiment qu'on a digéré sera si vous
voulez mettre une morale dans tout ça et
on revient un petit peu sur la
problématique que développer ce rallye
si la semaine dernière c'est à dire il
ya une homosexualité subversive et une
homosexualité normative et vous êtes
plutôt partisan de la seconde
mais non parce que j'ai 46 ans j'ai fait
partie de la l'homosexualité subversives
mais c'était avant l'arrivée du sida ça
va être subversif aujourd'hui qu'il ya
42 millions de personnes qui sont
touchées par cette maladie
c'est comme un pas possible on s'est
battu moi je me suis battu pendant 13
ans pour qu'il y ait des traitements
j'ai rencontré tous les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques en facilement travail
acteurs j'ai fait chier les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et le gouvernement est
maintenant qu'on a les traitements qu'on
est dans un pays où on a la chance
d'avoir les traitements il ya des mains
qui veulent être subversif en disant je
vais oublier la capote c'est pas de la
subversion c'est tout simplement de la
connerie est un moment il faut le
rappeler que c'est non seulement un
respect de soi même mais un respect des
autres
non
hier - point sur lequel ghisi laissera
faisait d'accord avec alain soral
c'est l'obsession des gays pour le pour
le shopping le le consumérisme le guet
alain soral dit la seule chose qui fait
qu'il ya une communauté homosexuelle
c'est le shopping moi je dis il ya
d'autres choses quand même il ya non
seulement le fait qu'on a fait partie
d'une minorité qui a mal vécu pendant
pas mal de temps et qui est encore il
n'ya pas longtemps il ya un mec dans le
nord qui s'appelle sébastien sébastien
boucher qui a été brûlé vif
et ça c'est de la vraie homophobie réel
1 est ce que je veux dire là dessus il
faut pas imaginer que la vie maintenant
elle est complètement facile pour les
homosexuels je crois que le consumérisme
c'est peut-être une façon de vivre les
choses plus vite quand peut-être on a
plus d'incertitudes sur l'avenir
ouais et je crois que quand même c'est
pas une excuse quand même pour oublier
de s'engager sur des choses qui sont
importants 1 c'est-à-dire le sida
actuellement il ya très peu de gens qui
sont intéressés par ce sujet mais je
crois que sur un sujet pareil on est
obligé d'avoir des gens qui de temps en
temps à bah ouais et oui c'est parti ça
que j'étais un petit peu déçu c'est le
sentiment qu'on a en lisant votre livre
déçu parce que finalement dans la
communauté gay l'individualisme a
remplacé l'idéalisme je crois oui un peu
mais je crois que c'est un peu le
principe d'immersion je crois qu'il faut
que les gens aillent mal pour qu'ils se
ressaisissent et je crois que c'est ce
qui s'est passé au début du sida ou
savez les gens se sont mobilisés au
début du sida parce qu'ils avaient peur
mais les gens se sont pas pris la capote
parce que c'était fans ils ont pris la
pac à la capote tout simplement parce
qu'il avait vraiment peur de mourir et
je crois que maintenant les gens ont
oublié ce que c'est cette maladie monde
même il suffit de voir mon visage il est
marqué et tout ça mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que vous voyez plus
maintenant des images de malades à la
télé vous envoyer plus est là dans les
vrais héros et à partir du moment où les
trithérapies sont arrivés c'est vrai
qu'on a commencé à dire bon dans les
médias on était content de considérer
que c'est un sujet qu'on pouvait mettre
de côté pour pouvoir parler notre choix
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plus est cet
enthousiasme qui avait au départ vous
dites par exemple la banalisation du
sexe vous citer un exemple dans votre
bouquin vous arrivez dans un mini bar
cuir il ya un mec qui est en train de
sucer
un autre en se faisant reculer il
continue à discuter comme si de rien
n'était vous dites que finalement une
espèce de banalisation du truc aux
actionnaires
il ya surtout des rapports qui sont plus
difficile maintenant entre homosexuels
et je crois que c'est le fond du
problème c'est le fond de ce livre
pourquoi l'épidémie reprend chez les
homosexuels c'est parce que je crois que
ils sont très durs les uns entre envers
les autres et se ils ont des systèmes de
drague maintenant qu'ils sont vraiment
qu'ils passent pas par le dialogue
qu'ils passent pas par 20 n'a pas envie
de savoir qui c'est on n'a pas envie de
se connaître
iliad vachement demain qui ont vraiment
très peur de tomber amoureux aujourd'hui
c'est quand même le monde à l'envers si
la culture du bas chrome quoi on y va
pour mais c'est là coûte la culture du
sexe qui est disponible qui est bien
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que ça a
eu un effet un peu pervers c'est à dire
que cette banalisation du sexe a fait
que maintenant les gens ont vraiment du
mal à communiquer et je crois que enfin
on le sexe c'est bien mais c'est quand
même juste un moyen quand même l'idée
c'est quand même de pouvoir se
rencontrer et de pouvoir à un moment
quand vous avez peur de parler à
quelqu'un parce que vous avez
l'impression que vous parlez trop ou
peut-être vous dit pas les choses qu'il
faut faire je veux dire ça veut dire que
les rapports de draguer les rapports de
communication commence à être un peu un
peu perverti je crois non mais quand je
dis vous êtes déçu c'est vrai même la
musique vous dites maintenant la musique
pour vous est passée au second plan
vous dites qu'elle était aussi aliénante
que le bareback finalement même
journaliste qui a beaucoup parlé de
house est un sujet bien sûr et que je
vois que c'est vrai que c'est une
musique et peut-être pas assez respecté
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que on
peut penser que j'ai un discours comme
ça très moralisateur mais c'est pas mon
réalisateur c'est de l'amour à l'est la
morale sais c'est pas forcément quelque
chose de mal dans la sexualité c'est
simplement c'est on a envie tout
simplement de bien traiter les gens un
essai et ça veut pas dire non plus de
d'être non plus une
est complètement idiot je crois que l'on
peut avoir de tout dans un monde et
quand je crois que cette façon de se
comporter d'une manière très dur ça
devient devient la normalité pour moi je
suis obligée d'intervenir parce que j'ai
46 ans et je suis obligé de rappeler
comment c'était il ya vingt ans il ya
dix ans ou quand même sur cette rue gay
ben c'était un peu plus sympa ouais mais
c'est pas sûr dans les gaz au lean
c'est paradoxal parce que les avantages
des gués maintenant son énorme envie
vraiment mieux mais c'est paradoxal à un
moment où on vit mieux que les
homosexuels entre ce traitement bien
souvent du mal à lormes le reste du
monde laurent fait moins c'est ça qui
est le grand paradoxe de te lire en
pensez quoi gérard de cette espèce d
pourrait dire d'effondrement des valeurs
d'une certaine façon on va les valeurs
homosexuels en tous les cas les valeurs
de la communauté gay on parle des
backrooms des choses comme ça je pense
que c'est très parisien est prêt
citadins il ya plein de gens qui savent
pas ce que c'est donc il ya aussi des
homosexuels qui disons pas dans les
backrooms bien sûr mais c'est moi en se
mettant des doigts et des bains et des
machins et qui sait mais et qui est et
qui font l'amour normalement quoi oui il
versait il n'y a pas un ghetto autant de
ghettos qu'on veut penser voilà ce que
non mais ce que je vais dire à partir du
moment si vous vous savez dans un mois
il va y avoir les premiers chiffres
officiels je suis entièrement d'accord
avec normes et surtout si dans un mois
vous avez une remontée vraiment
effective de l'épidémie chaise
homosexuels que vous alliez dans les
backrooms ou quoi tout le monde sera
vraiment concerné plaque en fait c'est
vrai qu'à une façon simple d'être
homosexuel et la façon d'act up qui
était très militante trop militants
attendent et on n'a jamais été trop
militant n'oubliez pas qu'en france on a
réussi à influencer la distribution des
médicaments qui ont sauvé des dizaines
de milliers de vies et vous pouvez dire
il ya bien sûr rectum ne peut pas être
bon et d'ailleurs je passe une grande
partie de mon bouquin à les critiquer
mais ce que je veux dire en tout cas sur
les traitements on a fait un boulot qui
est vraiment exemplaire dans le monde
exemple vous êtes abonné josé bové de la
capote mais oui c'est pour ça je les
admire
bien à quelqu'un de vous admirer pas du
tout hein c'est eric reynès ben oui
parce que je crois que c'est l'un des
deux un des deux écrivains homosexuels
qui a fait qui a basé sa carrière sur le
fait de dire qu' abandonner la capote
c'était plutôt fade
il monte en tant que militant je ne peux
pas accepter ça je suis obligé de me
mettre en colère
il est la voix s'y risquent